let's get to the news and and this falls
into one of those
polarizing yeah unintentionally
political buckets
right where you know we got to fight
about everything
we can't get on the same page about
anything in this country
it's depressing it's sad it is sad
exclamation point
but that's where we are and it intrudes
upon the nfl and people are going to
complain why are you talking about what
we're talking about
because it's one of the top stories
right now in the national football
league because the nfl and the nflpa
chris have
have finalized and nothing's ever final
until it's actually implemented and even
then it can be changed but for now
they have finalized the procedures for
covert 19 protocols 2021 training camp
preseason regular season and there is a
clear dividing line
those who have been vaccinated those who
have not
been vaccinated and surprise surprise
if you make the quote-unquote personal
choice
to not be vaccinated it's still 20 20
for you
yeah you're still subject to the same
requirements
up your nose with a rubber hose every
morning right for a test
mask on in the facility all the things
that applied last year
apply this year if you choose to get
fully vaccinated if you get it
accomplished before the start of
training camp
you get treated differently and that's
just the way it is
you know a lot of a lot of unvaccinated
players pissed off about this
sorry guys that's the way it is yeah
what do you want joe mixon
went a little cuckoo on right social
media yesterday over this matt at the
nfl pa what do you what do you want joe
do you want the guys who were vaccinated
to be tested every day
and have masks on every day and not be
allowed to congregate outside the
facility
is that fairness i mean well what i
don't understand what he wants
or does he want no restrictions to apply
to anyone even the ones who aren't
vaccinated it really is odd to me chris
but
this was inevitable yeah this is as if
guys aren't going to get vaccinated
there's going to be guys who get a
little upset when they realize
the ones who choose to get vaccinated
are going to have an easier time of it
this year
way easier let alone like these aren't
even the regular season protocols and
all of that and
you know who knows if what what the
close contact protocols will be whether
you're vaccinated or not vaccinated or
if you do test for positive for covid
somehow some way
and you've been vaccinated those rules
might be a lot easier you know two
negative tests and
three days of you know being away from
everybody and you're good to go right i
mean that's some of the stuff they do
in the nba right now with that type of
stuff with vaccinated players so even
that would be less
as well if that happened but like
i mean mike listen this it goes back to
the beginning of time when we started
covet right
what was the first thing i said to you
about nfl players in covid
right and they don't care about it they
don't give a damn about it they don't
listen and and i think that's you know
that's an
issue obviously that they're fighting
through in the nfl right now
and the big thing is to where you talk
to players where you want to go
wait don't you want to play don't you
want your money
don't you want to be at your best and
you know know that you had all the
advantages and didn't have to you know
have the disadvantages of all you know
limited people in the weight room
because you're not vaccinated everything
else
you know don't you want that and of
course put your team in the best success
position to succeed as well that's where
you know
me as a guy as an ex-player and i will
say
have not been vaccinated yet and going
to on tuesday i have my appointment all
right i've been hesitant
but yeah it's the right thing to do it's
the best thing for society right now
and i think players who are these alpha
males and healthy and young
they just think let me fight it
naturally but it's not the best thing
for the league their careers and really
society at this point but
regardless of whether they believe and
they do
yeah that it's not going to affect them
that they can fight it off if they
should get it
the idea that if you get it and we we
have countless stories from last season
where guys get it no symptoms cam newton
no symptoms
it didn't let him
still play in that monday night game
against kansas city chiefs he still
wasn't allowed to play
right so you you've got this very simple
up or down yes or no test result and if
it's yes you can't play and i understand
if you're vaccinated and you still test
positive but still
it's it's it is it's going to be a
different reality if you're vaccinated
and
because what it doesn't be tested every
day that's the other side of it too
right you're not if you're not
vaccinated
every day you're rolling the dice on
whether or not you come back positive
if you're vaccinated you're not rolling
the dice every single day
it's going to be harder to even get
flagged and end up in the protocol but
my point is this
you know we've talked over the years
about toradol and peds and all this crap
that players will take
right just have injected into their
bodies to allow them to play
that's the thing that is that is amazing
to me yeah
that that for them the water's edge of
things they'll put in their bodies to
allow them to ensure they're going to
play
football is this vaccine well it's the
other ones are performance related right
so that's where it's a little different
this is perfect
i know you could argue it is because it
allows you to perform it's like toradol
allows you to perform
yeah i mean you're it's certainly going
to allow you to perform maybe at your
highest level you're right and not have
that
worry of like yeah will i test now
positive
you you you take off the table the
possibility that you will arbitrarily be
yanked out of the locker room and told
you can't go back for 10 days yeah
that's that
that's right that's a pretty strong
performance enhancer no
let alone you know you brought up cam
newton and all that
and we saw that he was not the same
after it
he talked about the cloudiness and the
brain and all those type of things and
then the one thing if you
you know you continue to look at the
research here
even though i'm not like the most yes
vaccine guy in the world
the the one thing you can't really argue
is of course
less deaths and less extreme cases you
know and from that standpoint too as a
player
you know here you are you only got a few
number of years to play in the nfl get
your money
do you really want to roll the dice on
maybe missing
four game checks and who knows what that
is depending on the player a million
dollars four million dollars i don't
know
just to not get vaccinated that's where
you know i come back to no matter how
you feel
i i just would tell players come on this
is this is one where
you know this is the right thing to do
for yourself your team your teammates
society everything about it says you
know
go that direction and i appreciate the
clarification from earlier i misspoke
these aren't the regular season
protocols yet but we know which way the
wind is blowing yeah it's not like it's
not like they're going to say
labor day week and you know what we've
just decided to get rid of any and all
protocols it's open seas and vaccinated
or non-vaccinated just come on
in show no there's still going to be a
distinction
and it's a safe bet that the distinction
just saw on the screen we've got the
full story at pft with all the different
things and it's
it's as simple as last year still
applies if you're not vaccinated
and 2019 rules are in effect if you are
it's pretty much
that that that's the distinction it's
going to be a huge
difference in reality and i think what
they're trying to get the players to do
and maybe joe mixon is working his way
through anger denial bargaining
depression acceptance
and if he can accelerate that quickly
enough he can get himself
fully vaccinated before the start of
camp they want guys to understand and i
think come to their own conclusion i
should probably get
the vaccine before they get tossed into
the gears of this
and have to live it this is out there
now this is the flag this is the sign
this is the warning here's how your life
is going to be if you show up at
training camp not fully vaccinated and
some guys are going to be upset
when they realize it because here's the
thing chris we've known which way the
wind is blowing here for months
but we pay attention to it the players
don't yeah that's right they just don't
right they don't
follow the the the the day the details
of the day-to-day news cycle they just
don't do it kirk morrison told me that
recently
he's got a radio show on espn's la
affiliate
and you know when you he said when
you're playing you really don't follow
it closely and then when you're not
playing and you're in the media you do
it you just do and uh you know there are
guys
in every locker room right now who are
focused on wrapping up the offseason
program and whatever they're going to do
over the next month and they're not
thinking about
well and they have no sense of what the
rules are going to be and yesterday they
got the cold splash of water in their
face
right and and i think a lot of guys
probably felt the way joe mixon did no i
i think so yeah i think there's a lot of
players that are unaware of you know
where this is going and you know you
make up that you make the point of like
yeah guys are going to be upset when
they get to training camp and they're
not vaccinated all those type of things
you know also i just point to it like
man don't you want your some of your
civil liberties back too
i i can't lie one of the things that's
going to you know
hurry me up to getting the vax the
vaccine
is looking at other guys here at work
who are vaccinated they got no mass they
don't have to worry about certain
protocols coming in the building they
don't have to do that every day
you know i'm still wearing my mask
around and stuff like that
that's just annoying in itself let alone
i'm not gonna have to go through nfl
protocols and the things they're gonna
do
so you know again i think it is a little
bit of lack of information
you got alpha males who are young and
healthy and feel like they'd rather just
have this naturally
or deal with it naturally in their
natural immune system and all those type
of things
but i just don't think they're realizing
the limitations it's going to put on
their football career
and some of the repercussions that could
possibly happen
you know you know whether it is missed
games because a failed test or
you know again we've seen you know
players like reque
raquel thompson right the running back
from the jacksonville jaguars armstead
excuse me tom said i'm saying
raquel armstead who missed a whole year
of last year because of covet and those
things so you know there's a lot of
a lot of things i think to point the
players into saying
hey even if you don't love the idea of
the vaccination which i don't either
i think there's more positives than
negatives when it's all said and done
and especially
as it applies to their careers you know
i i thought about you last week
on the issue of the vaccine and whether
or not you were going to do it because
if you got any plans on
making the rounds at training camps this
year you ain't getting in if you're not
i know vaccinated i know
media is not getting in right and and so
you know the players think they're being
treated unfairly because they still have
these limitations
anyone in the media who has decided that
you know on whatever basis yeah from the
legitimate to the ridiculously kooky it
puts magnetic crystals in your body
whatever your basis if you choose not to
do it you ain't getting in
as media you're just not getting in
period so uh that that's part of this as
well
here's mike zimmer vikings head coach
meeting with reporters yesterday when he
he laid pretty uh bluntly as he tends to
do
yeah the reality is for the players who
choose not to get vaccinated
we're just trying to educate these guys
you know they have to make their own
decisions
um you know the unvaccinated players are
going to have a harder time
in the season they're going to be
wearing masks they'll have to social
distance
you know they'll have daily testing they
won't be able to go
go home for bye week they'll have to
come back here and test every day
when we go on the road they won't be
able to
to go out to dinner with anybody they'll
have to travel on
buses differently uh travel on planes
differently
so you know the meetings will be you
know they'll some a lot of meetings will
be
virtual like this is here and so there's
not not only this the safety part of
getting vaccinated
but as far as being part of a football
team
and um it's just going to be so much
easier you know like like with me for
instance you know i don't have to wear a
mask
i you know we have staff meeting the
other day we got
you know everybody's in the same room we
can sit there and talk as opposed to
trying to
do this like we're doing here and um you
know
i i know you guys know i don't really
like doing all the media stuff but
i'd much rather be sitting in a room
talking to you than looking up at this
camera and looking down at you
can you lobby to the pa to make that
happen for us because your voice carries
a lot stronger than ours does
um you know quite honest courtney
i think uh i'm more inclined to help the
players the best i can than you
have a good day thank
good answer though you like it oh you
gotta love mike zimmer and that's the
thing they are trying to help the
players yeah
and and this is a delicate balance
because most coaches are wired
to get right in your face and tell you
how it is i'm reminded of the scene from
remember the titans when denzel
washington is telling the guy football
isn't fun
zero fun sir i mean you tell them how it
is yeah
from day one this is how it is
and it's got to be so counter-intuitive
for guys like mike zimmer
bruce sarians mike tom although you know
tomlin's still telling them how it is
that oh by the way the steelers are all
vaccinated
but you know some of them have some of
them have a greater
degree of gifts than others when it
comes to telling players how it is yeah
but for some of them you got to be
careful
because you don't if you swing and miss
on this you got a fractured locker room
sure and you got guys there
who who all of a sudden they're not
going to listen to you on that
and maybe they're not going to listen to
you on other things no doubt about it
you gotta i feel like as a coach you got
to approach it from like the education
process like you're talking about you
know like mike zimmer has talked about
help these guys out if you sound like
you're you know
napoleon or mussolini and you're telling
like yelling at guys
and doing all that but i'm still i don't
think i think mike tomlin all he has to
do because he knows how to connect with
each individual he sure
said he's developing that personal
relationship right dwayne haskins as
they
possibly find their future quarterback
you know
on on not even on waivers just available
hey you get him for the minimum but
uh i think he's got that gift where he
can walk up to these guys and just tell
them how it is and tell them what they
need to do and they're going to do it no
doubt about it or he spreads word
through the captains of the team who he
knows or wired like he
is or whatever and hey you better tell
these dudes they better get their
vaccinations if they want to be all in
practice and get on this team and that
type of stuff like
word will spread the right way you're
right well and he's got the magic touch
also where i think you know
as long as you're not too preachy and
just you know forcing it on people too
the other thing that i think is
interesting at least to where the
coaches can win over players that are
skeptical or on the fence
a lot of the coaches didn't want to get
vaccinated i mean i think you know that
you've heard a lot enough stories at
least i have
you know i know there's some that but i
think there was a lot more resistance
than we even
actually know of but they realize like
wait it's what i gotta do
this is what i gotta do for work a lot
of those coaches are wired like the
players are in that way where it's just
like i don't care about cole but i'm a
tough man i play football and do that
but they did it for the better of their
life
the team everything like that and maybe
that could help the players too
you're speaking to a a deeper issue here
yeah
that crosses the lines of sport into
society at large and i this is a real
question
yeah when did when did we become right
a nation of five-year-olds
who don't like being told what's good
for us
like why is it that when you tell
someone what's good for them
now it's acceptable to say i'm not doing
it well
but did you need to well i'm not doing
it i'm not don't tell me don't act like
you know
i like but but you're being you're
acting like you're five years old like
well
i i don't understand that chris why all
of a sudden that's just the way it is
you gotta tread lightly i i i made this
observation on twitter last week
sure that it takes courage to speak
truth to power and nowadays it takes
even more courage to speak truth to
stupid it was a great tweet
i love that it was one of your best uh
of recent memory yeah that's a low bar
well but but i mean i i hear you
but this is it's also about you know
it's a deeper issue too
people have been scorned by the
pharmaceutical industry
i know we've talked about that so there
are people that don't totally trust it
all the way
i'm one that is a little bit of no
trust okay and a little bit of yes i'm
young and i'm blood type oh and i
i'm a little bit of the thought of i'd
like to do it you know
naturally in those type of things as
well and
you know also i was also kind of just
like well
maybe there's going to be another
variant and maybe they're going to come
out with a better
vaccine that was i was kind of one of
those guys i'm not anti-vaxx i just was
kind of like that like
let me wait a little longer and see but
i realize the writing's on the wall you
see the evidence right now
you know through the cdc numbers the
numbers going down with deaths
hospitalization rates all those type of
things
especially in the vaccinated states and
you see in the states that are not
vaccinated
it's the opposite so like that's where i
would preach to players like come on
it's time to just you know jump on the
bandwagon i know it's not perfect
and you might not like it but it's it's
the best thing to do here
there was like one of the most obvious
news blurbs i've ever seen over the
weekend that
breaking covet cases up in those who
aren't vaccinated covet cases down
in those who are ing thanks but maybe
that's the kind of simplicity it takes
to bust through the shell and look i i
think that this is all a product of the
algorithms that are fed to people by
their social media 100
100 and it's a it's a long standing
overtime brainwashing it
excuse us in these two separate
directions whoever's behind it
the russians someone else space aliens
they're winning i don't know they're
winning
but they're winning they are because
they're they they know how
to to find the people who are
predisposed to
behave a certain way feed them over and
over again with only the slant on
reality yeah
that that that they've been clicking on
right yeah
and it just creates this divide where
it's impossible to tell people
the way it is because for the same
reason that you or i would say to
someone
why don't you see the obvious truth
their response would be
why don't you see the obvious truth
and good luck bridging that gap um
another truth that we're dealing with
in the world of vaccinations
intersecting with the nfl
right the philosophical question
of whether or not it's anyone's business
that a player
has or hasn't been vaccinated let's hear
from some of the quarterbacks yesterday
on both sides of the vaccination
question
talking about or not talking about
whether or not they've received the
shots
i haven't talked to to too many people
about it uh you know there's a small
group of guys that have been vaccinated
and i've been vaccinated and
you know i thought if it's if it's
available and
and to be able to do all these things it
helped me in the long run and um
you know i i think it's better for
everyone and but it's it's up to
everyone so it's their opinion and
um you know i think it's a tough
situation regardless you know just like
everyone in the society
you know is their decision stuff like
that um
keeping that to themselves but you know
i feel we do a great job here of
you know taking the vaccine and keep
staying away from cove and stuff like
that follow the right preparation and
stuff for that
and staying away from the outside to the
people that's attracting it
and we just got to keep it going because
no one i haven't been hearing by any
breakout so
just like you know like last year the
previous year before this one
with all the stuff that was going on
people catching it left and right i
haven't been hearing anybody so i feel
like this year has been doing great
everyone's been doing a great job better
just keep going
and that's just a personal uh thing with
everyone on the team and
you know no matter what people decide to
do we're going to make it we're going to
make it work
in whichever way
so look lamar jackson justin hurt were
also kirk cousins yesterday their
attitude was i'm not talking about
whether or not
i got vaccinated now some of lamar
jackson's comments mildly ironic given
the outbreak the ravens had
yeah last year uh no no the ravens did
not do a great job and and it was
impossible to do
a 100 job of keeping it out of the
building right
and and it's still going to be an issue
for the guys who aren't vaccinated but
you know justin herbert he made it clear
he's been vaccinated
he talks to teammates he's got a biology
degree from oregon
about the vaccine and even then you're
not going to change guys minds because
they're not
actively looking there there was a a
report recently that
i think it was albertpierre of si.com
one general manager said that
the team got more questions about
toradol far more questions about toradol
than about the vaccine yeah in the same
period of time because the nflpa's
recommended
even more restricted use of toradol but
chris you know
i've seen some in the media try to shout
down anyone who would ask players
whether or not they've been vaccinated
this goes directly to your potential
availability
it's no different than any other injury
or health condition that could keep you
off the field it's fair game if you're
going to play in the nfl
you can't say well my these are my
personal medical records no it's
have you been vaccinated or have you not
because
we need to know we need to know we the
people who follow the sport
the people who root for the teams the
people who have fantasy football teams
with money on the line
legally the people who bet on games
legally
or illegally they need to know they need
to know who to worry about
they need to know who's who's going to
be available and who's not going to be
available potentially and it's a fair
question and yeah it doesn't matter if
you don't test positive
but i think it's a fair question for
everyone
and i i i've asked the league
will there be lists published of who's
vaccinated and who's not they haven't
responded to me yet
yeah well they're still figuring but i
think it's i think it's fair i think
it's fair
for everyone to know who's been
vaccinated and who hasn't been yeah
that's a tough one i mean i it really is
now the nfl yeah they could do whatever
they want they could set their own rules
uh but i mean yeah it's hard
to tell people what to do and what to
put into their body
it is i do have compassion for that you
know
but but separate from that whether or
not they do it yeah whether or not they
do it should be fair game from an
information standpoint this is a sport
that's founded on transparency
and information especially as it relates
to availability and it's no different
than talking about someone's ankle
or and i heard somebody argued last
night well this is not football really
well if someone's got the flu
if someone has appendicitis if someone
has some other condition that affects
their ability to potentially play it's
still fair game there's no medical
secrets if you're going to play
professional football there are no
medical secrets you can't all of a
sudden start throwing hippa around even
though hipaa has no application here
whatsoever
doesn't stop people from throwing it
around no this is part of what you sign
up for and i don't like playing that
card
this is what you sign up for but what
this goes with the territory
there are no secrets chris when you had
your spleen out you do a press
conference talking all about your spleen
and
clean this and spleen that you talk
about the surgery and your recovery
right
it's an open book that's the way it
works in the nfl it is
it's hard to argue that point a hundred
percent now i mean i don't know if they
need to like send out a list to say
you're available or not but like
or like oh hey you know the game's over
and we're gonna talk to zach wilson on
zoom
and he's in the next room then obviously
we know he hasn't been vaccinated i mean
i mean that's that's the way i think
that can go down without the nfl maybe
pissing the players off by like sending
out a list to just go
hey hey media here's all the guys that
aren't vaccinated they're kind of just
going to let you figure out through
the rules and protocols of the of the
game and everything that way
so that's where it's interesting you
know the players everything that you
talk
you've talked about there's
misinformation you know there's a lot of
that
players are confused they're alpha males
also in the fact that they like i said
they don't give a damn about covid they
think they could do that
they see the news of you know some teams
who have been vaccinated had
outbreaks or chris paul recently who's
you know vaccinated and he's now in a
protocol
for the nba during the playoffs and
might not be able to play
so like i think all of these things are
leading some of these young
these are young men for the most part to
be a little bit hesitant about the whole
thing and they're kind of trying to take
this all into account and figure out
what to do
but you know as you're saying the nfl
makes the rules here
that's that's that's the way it is and
they're gonna
have to figure out how easy or hard they
want to make life for themselves in this
2021 season
well and part of it too is and we
touched on this earlier the influences
around you the teammates the coaches
family members it can become a stew of
conflicting
signals and messages and it puts the
individual sometimes in a tough spot
if you've got a parent or a spouse or a
loved one
who is strongly anti-vaccine and is
constantly saying don't you get that
shot don't you get that shot
and you're you're getting the pressure
from coach team leader
trainer etc you probably should get the
shot that that's going to create some
real havoc for that person yeah
it is it's definitely going to cause
havoc for that person there's no doubt
and here you know listen
i understand there's there's still
unknowns out there a little bit
like i do i do wonder this right with
like the chris paul situation i don't
know how aware you are fully vaccinated
did everything the right way
all of that but somehow is in the
protocol
like i i i mean i don't know where i'm
going with this i i basically
i don't know enough about what's going
on in the nba i don't know how he does
the flag
that's what i'm curious about how do you
even get because they're still getting
tested even they're vaccinated see
that's the other thing where i wanted to
go with it
how do we know all these people that are
vaccinated still don't have
the sickness and can pass it along those
are things we don't know yet now
obviously maybe it's not being passed
along quite as aggressively
but i mean i see people who have colds
right now and i go
uh do you know if it's cold and they're
like well i've been vaccinated i want to
go well did you get tested
because i mean yeah you could also argue
and go yeah we've been vaccinated but
people aren't being tested the same way
anymore
either they're also just going well i've
been vaccinated i don't know what i have
right now i'm cold i'm coughing but
i've been vaccinated who cares and
that's some of the things i've heard
some players talk about through social
media too
and it's just another interesting case
that i think you know it's
to think about well and you know what as
you say that
i'm multitasking good i'm asking the
league
what the procedure is going to be for
testing the vaccinated players because
all we know from yesterday is there
won't be daily tests
right i mean you've got to be willing to
be tested at all what is the mechanism
if any for them to be flagged as being
coveted
it's an interesting thing and and i i
didn't mean to bring up something you
didn't know about the chris paul thing
and all that but
i didn't know what the i know i knew
about chris paul right because
i wrote about it yesterday the fact that
he tested positive and he's out
indefinitely
could be something that prompts nfl
players
to say i don't want that to happen to me
now it complicates things when
he was vaccinated i know but uh if if
they're not going to test the guys who
are vaccinated
it ain't going to happen yeah i know
that's the thing that's the that's the
ultimate litmus test you can't fail a
test you don't take
right so uh that's what we'll find out
and
and and here's how it goes i've i've
said this before so i don't think i'm
gonna get myself in trouble for saying
again
i'll send a question to the league
sometimes they respond right away
sometimes i got to ask two or three
times and
they probably know me well enough to
know that i've got a sufficiently short
attention span that i'll forget about it
and i'll move on
and now that i sit here and think about
it there's been a few questions i've
asked in the past week that i
forgot about and they never answered
we'll see we'll see what kind of answer
we get on this one but this is one
that's going to
follow the category of i'm going to keep
asking yeah until it's interesting
because i think it's an important one to
know the answer too yeah i agreed
it's something listen i'd like to know
more about certainly just as a guy
that's sitting here learning more about
it but
you know hey to button all this up and
everything like that
man as an nfl player wow you're rolling
the dice that's all i could say and i'm
not a guy that's been like yeah go get
the vaccine this second right
i'm just saying from an ex player been
around it my whole life
everything that looks like it's been put
in place you hear the coaches how hard
it was to communicate last year
all the bad things and annoying things
let alone like
lack of camaraderie i can't go we're
going to go play in a game
and i can't fly with the team i got to
go on the you know the other plane
with like the non-vaccinated guys and
not be with you guys while you go out to
eat maybe and all that that
that's enough to make me get vaccinated
if i'm a player i need the camaraderie
of the team the life the
the life and soul of the team that's
what gets you going as a football player
and uh that that's really i think the
thing that would bother me more than
anything
and that's why there's a very real
competitive component to this there is
the teams that get the higher
concentration of players vaccinated will
have a more
normal reality and the camaraderie will
be greater
and they'll be unified and they'll be
together and those walls won't be there
like there were last year and you could
say the walls will be even worse this
year because you've got two different
classes of players
at least last year everybody was in the
same yeah that's right this year you're
going to have
you're going to have the vaccinated who
are
in first class and you're going to have
the unvaccinated in coach
and the guys in coach are going to
resent the ones
in first class even though the ticket to
the
first class cabinet yeah right it's free
right
anyone can have it and it's not there's
nothing funny about it although there
are parts of it that are like
like why is this so complicated but it
is complicated yeah it is
and i hate i i heard something recently
that you know we we've been talking
about
the reality that when it's time to craft
the final 53-man roster
all things being equal the guy who's
vaccinated is going to be kept
yeah and the guy who isn't is going to
be cut that's a given now and the nflpa
is never going to be able to prove it
unless there's another brandon bean
moment we're coming out
someone comes out and says right yeah i
i i couldn't decide between
these two running backs one was
vaccinated one wasn't so i kept the one
that was vaccinated i heard that
that there's actually some teams
considering
cutting unvaccinated players before camp
yeah to increase the percentage
taking fewer than 90 to camp so you have
to the extent that they do have an 85
percent
magic number even greater team right
reductions and restrictions
right maybe you're gonna have 80 or 85
players when you go to
camp and have some other reason for it
but the truth is going to be
we're shedding the unvaccinated so our
percentage of vaccinated players
i won't be shocked i you know i don't
know
remember early last year i think we had
this conversation a little bit before
training camp the same thing because
i had a few coaches last year who were
dabbling with that idea
not that of course anyone was vaccinated
but the fact of
maybe we should make the roster smaller
just to decrease the chances of as many
people being around each other and
everything like that
so i don't doubt that and that does make
sense i mean
again you certainly you know hey 90 guys
at camp
that's great you can get away easily
with
oh if we got 90 guys here and 75 are
vaccinated
you you could dispose of the 15 and
certainly still make camp go
and not have really an issue especially
with the way the practice rules are now
with
no two a days every day and you know
limited contact and things like that to
where
you could and i would think some coaches
are
seriously gonna think about that for
sure mike
and also only three pre-season games
except for the cowboys and the steelers
who play in the hall of fame game you
got fewer reps live reps that need to be
handled yeah by guys on the roster so uh
keep an eye on that possibility and
again there will be some other reason
for it it will not be
we are just shedding unvaccinated cargo
from the roster but
that will be driving it at some level
and maybe that's the benefit of not
being fully transparent about who's
vaccinated and who isn't then it won't
be as obvious
to us who would be saying hey they cut
seven guys today and all seven of them
come from the unvaccinated player list
even though there's definitely going to
be
some of that going on all right let's
take hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports